president Trump facing big foreign
policy challenges including North Korea
Russia the Middle East and just in time
for all these developments our friend
anchor of special report Bret Baier has
a new book out that parallels today's
headlines it's called three days in
Moscow Ronald Reagan and the fall of the
Soviet empire
lucky for us Brett is right here in New
York with us Brett welcome thank you
tell us about the parallels well there's
a lot of parallels in the moments the
challenges there are obviously very
different personalities but Reagan used
a lot of bold language that Washington
foreign policy establishment kind of
really had a problem with back in the
day I thought it was too aggressive and
in that case you know Donald Trump's
tweets are similar in that way we'll see
if Donald Trump follows the guidelines
of these summits and how he got up from
the table if it didn't work I do want to
bring in the book you know the book is
here and it came out this week and I saw
you while talking about the books and
how Jesse is so prolific in his reading
so I brought the young readers which
also comes at big prints at the same
time you can color in the doors by Brett
Baier that allows you see that is creepy
is this the creepiest thing it's a honey
valley it almost looks like you but
because it's not like you it's just
freaky I keep you know I take this
everywhere that's really I travel on the
subway with it I've had three companies
say they really want to they really want
to do this yeah but I think you should
do it for the Children's Hospital
charity you know what you should do is
do a promotion with your book on Twitter
that if somebody shows a receipt of
buying your book they are part of the
auction for the bear what is going
through your mind when you get the five
tossing to you at 5:59 seriously it is
one of the most scary
parts of the day especially if it's gray
yes really don't know what just assume
it's gonna rhyme
Dana punch she just says I don't where's
there instances and not just with this
summit that Ronald Reagan had the one
that you write about here yeah but were
there instances where one of the parties
threatened to call it off yes Reykjavik
they got up and left so it goes Geneva
Reykjavik and then Washington DC and
Moscow and the reason this one is
important in Moscow is the final one and
he speaks to Moscow State University
students about freedom and democracy and
not like hitting them over the head that
we're better than you but sort of like a
Pied Piper like come and see why the
West is the way to go you know what's
interesting on that point I mean
obviously I think back I was covering
the Reagan White House this is
perestroika and he makes tremendous
inroads with Gorbachev but now we're
dealing with Putin and Putin has
rejected the West and all of our offers
and help in terms of coming in to the
Western world on capitalism yeah it's a
totally different he's trying to
recreate the Soviet Union expansionism
and Mikhail Gorbachev was a different
leader and Reagan saw that and that's
why I negotiated with them a little fact
in here Reagan and Gorbachev in Red
Square when they're walking around
Marlin Fitzwater whispers in his ear and
says all these people around you they're
not civilians they're KGB officers yeah
and one of them was believed to be
Vladimir Putin killing three days
so the title three days in Moscow I
thought it was about Trump's visit for
the pageant is really thrilled with some
news of the day just with you we just
did a block on the Trump Tower meetings
on jr. and the transcripts that came out
I'm just curious if you know some people
are saying oh there's tons of stuff in
here that could really change the tide
others saying it's a big nothing burger
I think that was Jesse what do you think
is there anything new here I do think
that's what Dana pointed out I'm at the
mana Ford notes is actually really
interesting the the notes in the meeting
I also think that Don jr. there's a lot
of calls for him to come back up and
testify because there's some hazy memory
there at the same time you look at this
New York Times piece about operation
what does it crossfire hurricane and in
deep in there it says a year later
there's still no evidence of you know
any the Trump officials colluding with
Russia and I think both sides of this
investigation we have a lot to learn and
we'll probably months away can I just be
on behalf of America say no one cares
okay no one cares the bear doesn't even
care
so Senate Intel comes out and says much
differently than house Intel oh yeah
Russia interfered and they favorite
trunk does that matter what matters that
they put it out and they were backing up
the intelligence community in in what
they were put on a bipartisan report in
a bipartisan report and we're gonna have
senator Lankford on special report
tonight to talk about that that's a good
guest yep Jesse you know I realize that
you love books so I want you to ask your
toughest question now that we have bret
baier right here how will you handle the
fact that Gutfeld might outsell you with
the monologues I like that he plugs my
book
I mean you got to kill me book out there
you got the Gutfeld thing coming up yeah
Ainsley's got a book out we have a lot
of books how will you feel if you don't
outsell all I'll feel like that bear
well those bears feeling pretty good
right now it's in the best seat the
house my lap right there before we go
just on a personal note what do you hear
from Charles Krauthammer our so I had
this email the other day he's doing
better his doctors say he's turned the
corner and he hopes to be back in you
know in the panel and on the panel great
here's wishing you all the best charlie
no you watch and does he watch to see
watching five so he watches the fine how
bears ourselves Charles it's a little
late for that I'm holding a bear with a
human face huh that's true yeah this is
where I am again yeah do you get
aggravated no I think it's good you know
I can always hear you laughing because I
think you're trying to do a serious show